[Musique]
je peux te demander quelque chose
comme demander tout ce que tu veux
est-ce que tu es comme ça aussi quand tu
travailles
[Musique]
depuis que je suis gamin j'ai toujours
pu être cet autre là
[Musique]
il fait tout ce qu'il a à faire
asseyez-vous lieutenant dites-moi ce qui
se passe vous êtes un homme libre
j'ai perdu 15 ans de ma vie j'ai cru que
j'avais tué cette fille tu m'as fait de
mal à personne c'était un tueur à gage
quelqu'un m'a piégé
tu dois pas laisser de voir il refera
on en a encore après moi c'est pas
terminé
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai envie de reprendre du
service pourquoi pas
[Musique]
tu voulais pas reprendre le travail
alors mets-toi au travail tu lianes
[Musique]
j'irai jamais me frotter à des gens
aussi puissants
[Musique]
payés pour partir